so everyone knows that Santa Claus lives
at the North Pole more specifically he
actually lives in the Svalbard
archipelago which is the northernmost
human settlement in the world Paul Bob
is the only place on earth where you
don't need a visa the enzymes however
their 2600 inhabitants must have been
totally self-sufficient and they also
have to carry a gun whenever they leave
the main town
this isn't to defend themselves from
each other but rather to defend
themselves from the polar bears which
tend to roam around the region but small
birds which belongs to the kingdom of
Norway is the hot spot of a political
dispute with Russia interestingly this
frozen region has a pretty good chance
of becoming at the next Dubai although
certainly not when it comes to the
weather
phobar has one of the biggest oil beds
in the world further they are the
Gateway to the Arctic routes which might
just become one of the most important
pathways to international trade and this
is why small bar is more than an
ordinary territorial dispute
[Music]
we are talking about a potential new
Cold War involving the United States
Canada and even China and today that's
the story we're going to tell you about
[Applause]
[Music]
let's imagine a land with open doors
immigrants no matter where they come
from a place where a military presence
is forbidden because it's a
demilitarized zone a place which is a
fiscal haven that has the average salary
of Norway well this place that exists
and it's called slow baths and yes it's
at the North Pole also if you want to go
just fall bad there's no need to worry
about catching a cold or the flu the
extremely cold temperatures make it
impossible for viruses and bacteria stay
there and in their capital Longyear bein
you can find the world biggest liquor
collection one strike on ya from the
19th century or maybe a rare whisky
welcomes burger pub is the place to go
so let me introduce you to its owner
Steve Dalton many many different people
from many different nations working with
many different things first of all the
one of the biggest is absolutely the
coal mining company they have beamed the
coal mining company for 100 years six
excellent
today there is more and more people
working with in the tourist business a
service like restaurant bars but also
there is a lot of science going on on
small barge so at the beginning of the
20th century all that was a no man's
land and only some whale fishermen would
dare go to this place
nevertheless after the first world war
nearly all countries find something
called the Svalbard Treaty in this
treaty it is written the Norway holds
sovereignty over the territory but there
are some restrictions for one they
contend in their army they also can't
build a headquarters or a stronghold and
they must allow every citizen and every
company no matter where they are from
to enter the island and exploited
natural resources and this is how two
cities were born on the one hand we had
long year bein where the majority of the
population is Norwegian on the other
hand there is Boren's Berg with a
Russian majority in both of these cases
they started as coal mining settlement
every year there is or two times a year
they're like sports contest between the
settlements did Boris Bergen long
Libyans
and so now you might be wondering where
exactly do these mining companies pay
their taxes in small Bart well despite
being a Norwegian territory just filed
our treaty forbids any country from
taxing the profits this means their
citizens pay the minimum required amount
to finance their own governance in other
words as Fahlberg could be considered a
fiscal haven they have no the AG and
their corporate tax goes up to 16
percent which is even lower than
Singapore's
the last 10 15 years have been a lot of
people coming to long way from many
different places today there is like 46
different nations living in in the
Norwegian settlements along with bein
all these different nations live very
good together with each other and young
again we have an every year that is
lloyd Capone's pilum celebrating there
you have the Russian and you have the
Swedish strong but make no mistake all
those time Russian and Swedish people
are not coming to small bars are just
for the low taxes or the coal mines as
you might imagine getting called from
the north poles of the rest of the world
is pretty expensive and it's not a very
profitable business
small barred coal mine halts production
and so now you might be wondering well
if Cole's not profitable why are there
so many people going there it's probably
not for the balmy weather during winters
fall bard has a never-ending night where
there is not even a single minute of
daylight of course several people in
lived that work in science research
centers which are based on the
archipelago indeed since 2008 Farber has
hosted the global Seed Vault this is a
storage location paid for mainly by the
Bill and Melinda Gates Foundation and
Microsoft in this vault there is stored
a vast collection of seeds from most of
the plants that exists in the world in
case of a nuclear holocaust mankind
would be able to replumb the planet
thanks to this great vault but this is
still not the reason why farbod is so
important in fact there is something
more interesting than coal polar-bear
science or even Santa Claus in
[Music]
they Arctic holds an estimated 13% or 90
billion barrels of the world's
undiscovered conventional oil resources
and 30% of its undiscovered conventional
natural gas resources ah
yes they have oil there's not only that
let's imagine for a second that you want
to ship some goods from London to Tokyo
today in the past history would be to
take good
but imagine you can instead do edge
music this week
see what's going on here this is almost
half of the distance this means less
spending and faster logistics technology
and climate change are making it
possible to travel through the Arctic
Ocean and this would be a turning point
in international trade and one day this
is going to be a reality and on this
day's fall bart has the highest chance
of becoming the architect capital
the rest of the islands belong to
Russians have no human population
Greenland's on the other hand has a
chaotic legal system Samba has a strong
political system and good infrastructure
the proof is in this very interview with
Steve which was conducted through Skype
but do you weigh just a moment because
the best pass is yet to come
[Music]
frozen war for the Arctic all Arctic oil
is under the feet
this means the above the ground land of
Svalbard has no oil beds at least that
we know of all their wealth is on the
so-called continental shelf this is the
underwater landmass which extends from a
continent no deeper than 200 meters
according to international law the
continental shelf belongs to the country
that it is attached to and of course
this includes all of the resources
beneath so it should be the government
of the country who decides whether they
want to exploit this resource or not and
yes both Norway and starburns
archipelagos are on the same continental
shelf
therefore in normal conditions the
Norwegian government would have
sovereignty over this oil but remember
what we said about the salvage treating
every country can exploit the resources
and Norway can do nothing to stop them
so what exactly is the problem here well
best of the treaty actually says nothing
about the continental shelf or anything
under the water at all at the end of the
day when it was signed and all was
really thinking about extracting oils on
the bottom of the ocean and this is why
news like this makes people so nervous
but he believes no way is violating the
Svalbard Treaty when the Norwegian
government opens 3 blocks for oil
drilling in the barren sea close to the
Arctic Archipelago
in summary Russia says the Continental
shelfs fall board should be ruled by the
treaty and be exploited by any country
but Norway claims that since the legal
text didn't contain anything about this
the oil and the rights to extract it
belong to them and now we come to Russia
[Music]
they might still be thinking that this
north pole thing there's a small story
one of those things vaca demux and
diplomats to have discussions about
while having dinner but the truth is
that were having here Putin centers Vice
Prime Minister Dmitry Rogozin made a
controversial visit to the archipelago
it's the cold war in the Arctic Russia
says its Deputy Prime Minister had every
right to visit a Norwegian island near
the North Pole
despite travel restrictions imposed on
him over the conflict in Ukraine Norway
has condemned the trip and asked for an
explanation
this visit turns small valve into a
fashionable tourist destination among
Russians in last two years as far as
tourism has increased by 500% now as I
mentioned at the beginning there are two
villages on the main islands one is
Norwegian and one is Russia the Russian
one is called Barentsburg and there's a
population of less than 500 people
incredibly in 2015 alone they had more
than 60,000 tourists visit this island
[Music]
so now you might be wondering why the
Russian tourism is so important to small
bark well that's because it helps to
retain population but they're in in
Boris food out there there are more on
there like the system where you have the
radical companies everything and you're
eating in the contine and you it's not
necessary to buy your food soft place so
for a that's our understanding and the
Russian sentiment there is no currency
the mining company takes care everything
something like this biggest happened in
the Norwegian settlement - but then
tourism started and that brought all new
kinds of businesses and many different
people so they are in the beginning of a
process on the same way as we have been
doing it in long again they lost 25 30
years but do you watch out because here
we're talking about oil and influence in
what might become one of the main ocean
shipping routes in the world in fact
even China is trying to buy a property
here but that's a whole different issue
and mount something really talked about
in a future video
[Music]
and so we've given you our opinion here
a visual politic and now we'd love to
know yours what do you think of spa bars
do you think it will become a new ones
or are the frozen Dubai should Norway
let Russia exploit this foul barred oil
a lot of snow in the comments section
below we'd love to hear from you and
don't forget that we put our brand new
videos every Monday and Thursday so do
not forget to subscribe to our channel
for brand new videos also if you did
like this video please do give it a
thumbs up below it helps us out and as
always I'll see you next time and if you
want to learn more of our politics and
here even more of my lovely voice you
can join us at reconsider media we have
a podcast at reconsider mediacom slash
podcast see you then
[Music]
you